luckily we do have someone who can give
us more out more insights and i think we
can get him on the show now so this is
the first time that we are having a
guest with live translation so thank you
our tech hero felix for sorting sorting
this out and we're very lucky to have
andree toos um who is the former
spokesperson of the zaparizia nuclear
plant andrew thank you for joining us
hello hi nice to see you
thank you so much and hello to dimitro
in the background
uh dimitro is just gone that's not good
hopefully we'll get demetro back
in a minute
yeah we have dimitro on uh audio but not
on video
but as i say dimitro is a dw colleague
not a professional interpreter so we're
very lucky that he uh accepted to give
us a helping hand that's true today okay
we think dimitro is back dimitro can you
hear me okay
yes i can hear you
no worries no worries and as i say thank
you so much for uh coming on to uh
interpret for us
so um thank you and uh probably uh you
should start with uh
and really uh telling us about his
experience in uh in zappos right
that would be that would be i think a a
good thing to to start with indeed
andrey yeah would you would you be able
to tell us uh what your job at zapresia
involved and when you left
uh
[Music]
my experience is that i wouldn't wish
anybody to live through it
but to start with i worked
in the parisian nuclear power plant
since 2012.
wow so a long time already and i work 10
years on the british power plant and
last time i have a position at pt
it's mean
i work in public relationships and
when war started and russian troops
occupied
our plant
i must
[Music]
this uh
situation uh
talk about the situation uh
in facebook in
another
social media uh
to uh
show situation for all world because uh
at first of march uh
it's the sort of match at night uh when
the troops come to nuclear power plant
and open fire on a nuclear unit on
building near nuclear unit
it's very dangerous it's a high risk for
nuclear accident
and it's
very scared me
nobody
think
then
russian troops open fire on nuclear
power plant and it's very dangerous but
after occupied
we must work because
people who work in a nuclear plant
must
[Music]
do all for
safety for new class safety it's a first
priority
[Music]
on
another
options
it's the first
and
[Music]
it's not
[Music]
it's very difficult because
we have high risk
with
[Music]
explored
some
russian weapons and it's destroyed
[Music]
our equip
mount
[Music]
and it's human risk because
humans who must
saw all parameters
control temperature control pressure and
another parameters and nuclear power
plant
can't do
it
do
work uh very good because
behind
stay russian troops with a gun and it's
not impossible it's
all workers
really care care uh
scared about
family about children about
friends who stay in ergod
and
it's very difficult it's chernobyl
accident
[Music]
it's uh once it's
human
human
[Music]
formal cap it's created metropolis
it was a human mistake so so
human factor during the chernobyl
nuclear exit
incident
yes so it's very
nuclear power plant when russian troops
opened fire again opened fire on
the city
[Music]
uh when all people who work in nuclear
power plant live
[Music]
it's very dangerous because it's more
dangerous now
more than uh start of march
because when russian troops um
shelling shelling even russian
nuclear power units
it's um
damage from outside
but
now
when we lose some
systems security system for safety we
lose
[Music]
a line
[Music]
who
lined this
connection
energy system of ukraine
we
we can
lose
electricity for pumps
and pumps
all time must
work
for cooling nuclear fuel
and if we lose
electricity for these pumps and these
pumps
stop
we
have not cooling and
we have nuclear accident it's
hundred percent
because uh
nuclear fuel all time nuclear fuel
in inside reactor all-time
hitting
and
water
around nuclear fuel
was boiling
and
[Music]
i think dmitry helped me
[Music]
[Music]
um
explain the physical process of what's
going on when uh the reactor is not
cooled enough and it's not cooled enough
then uh
starts a zirconium reaction which would
actually lead to the uh hydrogen
explosion
happened in fukushima yeah
okay um
and it's very dangerous because it's uh
it's
uh the dangerous it's uh
from inside inside and uh it's a that
was a strong
the physical process is going inside the
reactor so it's not you know outside
pressure but it's going inside and it's
very difficult to control this process
as i understand
um
incident
so because of uh russian troops staying
around the nuclear plant and actually
on site of the nuclear plant
the ukrainian side is losing the control
it's losing actually
the
possibility to control this properly
these reactions and these processes
which are going inside the nuclear
reactors
and it's very dangerous because uh
well late it could lead to the uh
nuclear accident okay
okay thank you dimitro for the
translation um this is um very scary but
also very interesting i just want to
remind um the community if you want to
ask questions you can ping them in the
chat and the hell will take care of you
actually we have a first question if we
can bring that up uh our user voldemort
says uh andre when did you leave and
were the russians bothering you
[Music]
[Music]
so on
on june 90th
i had to leave uh
energy i had to evacuate
but on june 29th i was
21 21
21 yeah uh uh
on june 21st uh i was captured by
russians and
i was actually kidnapped and
i was transferred to sochi such as a
city on the black seashore in russia
where i was
kept in imprisoned i was tortured
i was uh set to
actually
to say something that i didn't want to
say
so
yeah that was my experience
andre actually had no idea that this has
happened to you then how did you
get
out and get to safety in
in the u.s
[Music]
so i i had to spend 20 days with russian
special services
and after after after after a while they
realized that they cannot get anything
from me they used me for propaganda
they wanted to you know extract some
information from me but after a while
they decided that
they couldn't get anything more and
they released me they gave me back my
documents and i had an opportunity to
to go through russia
to europe and
then to the united states and now i'm
studying in the united states but my
study program was planned long long
before
all this started invasion yeah okay
and andres do you feel safe now where
you are
um
[Music]
[Music]
uh i didn't feel safe anywhere in europe
even in switzerland i didn't feel safe
because i knew that uh russians are
able to reach you anywhere actually
they
they threatened me when they returned my
documents they reminded me about skripal
family
and about novichok
that they used to poison them
yeah and and they said that if i will
reveal any information of what happened
to me about torture
they would actually uh
do something to my mother or to me
and even now in the united states i do
do not feel completely safe i'm
always looking around and uh
i'm i'm feeling uh endangered even in
the united states
uh well because of of the russian
experience of using uh poison and other
ways to get rid of of their opponents
andre is your family done with you or is
your mother and the others
[Music]
foreign
right now i'm in the united states i'm
in the u.s alone my mother is in europe
she's in
the safe place
but in future we would like to go back
to ukraine
because
home
home is the best
and we are just worrying about other
people who stay there
and
we're worrying about their fate
i'm so sorry for what you've had to go
through and clearly the workers back in
ukraine are also working in very tough
conditions
um i'm wondering
i mean there are hundreds of workers who
are still in the plant
why haven't they fled is it from a sense
of duty
[Music]
um
foreign
uh for me uh the workers who are staying
at the plant they're real heroes because
they understand that
they have to control nuclear processes
so nuclear power plant is not like a
confectionery factory that you may just
switch it off and go back to home
the physical the
nuclear processes they should be
controlled
around the clock every day
and even uh during the
disconnection of the power uh lines that
happened uh
several days ago in ukraine uh the
management
of of the nuclear power plant went
to the plant and russian soldiers uh at
gunpoint said them
to go away but they
still persisted and they said that you
you you could do anything to us but we
should go and control this process
so for me the
workers who are staying at the plans
they're real heroes
thank you for the translation dimitro um
andre there's so much respect uh coming
from the community to you right now um
yeah we
are so sorry to hear about the the
trauma you've gone through but people
are really expressing their their
gratitude
um i wanted to know other russian
soldiers do they not understand the
risks
and
why are they not
more concerned about
what an accident could look like
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
russian soldiers do not really realize
what's going on they don't know what's
uh what what could happen they just
follow the orders
the orders from the superiors
who are somewhere
far far away from from the nuclear plant
and who who will be safe if something
will happen so
we have the experience in chernobyl it's
another nuclear power plant uh
decommissioned nuclear power plant
uh which was occupied in march uh
uh by russian troops so david digging uh
in in the very dangerous areas
where radiation levels are very high but
they were giving orders to
dig the trenches and they were doing it
so the same situation is here they just
follow the orders
and in case if something will happen
ukraine will be the country which
suffers the most because the nuclear
waste will will be you know
all around ukraine
uh
and um
so
this is it's really very dangerous
situations it's in nuclear terrorism
because russian troops they're shelling
uh the city uh
uh to provoke uh
the situation they're also hiding in in
in this safety in the
safety of nuclear power plant because
they know that ukrainian troops
wouldn't fire
in return
you know in the fear of nuclear accident
so they're provoking the
the world it's it's a nuclear terrorism
and ukraine needs
support of the world community to stop
this terrorism
we have a question from the community
our user fidel fey wants to ask how many
people are still working at the plant
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
before before the invasion started
the total staff
of the power plant was
12 000
workers
uh
at the moment when when the invasion
invasion began
uh probably we had like
8 000 workers because some of them were
on leave some of them were
sick
what can i say about the
current situation i i cannot give you
any numbers because it's uh
confidential information
but i i can give you some calculation so
every
day
there are several shifts working on the
power plant and one shift is eight hours
it's approximately five to six hundred
people
so it means that
around the clock uh
probably around 1
500 people
should be working
at the station
and um i can
estimate that right now probably five to
six thousand workers are still active uh
at the station
as a plant
okay and is that
anywhere near enough to
keep it running safely
so
actually it's the
minimum the minimum number uh that is
needed to run the plan safely
i suppose the people who are still going
to work despite
the
extreme risk they're facing they i guess
they know that they are the
the last standing blocks keeping this
plant safe
is
[Music]
yes the workers keep keep going to the
job
uh because they feel responsibility
for the nuclear safety even so
they go under shelling
i i keep contact with many of them and
they say well today
today i had a shell coming right into my
house and
now i have to clean clean the place or
somebody's car was burned
okay because it's not just the work that
they're facing
the the shelling the violence and it's
also of course in their homes
uh yes exactly it's it's uh
the whole city is under attack
there's there's so many things we we we
could still ask you we don't want to we
don't want to keep you long there's so
much respect again from from the
community uh expressing sympathy and
respect for people still working at the
prana upon and also for you andrei
um i would i would like to know despite
the threats you've received from russia
and despite
your experience of being directly
kidnapped even
and tortured why are you
motivated to
speak out to us and to other to other
media
um
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
uh i'm i'm telling you because i'm i
finally have freedom of expression i'm
i'm free to tell the truth and i will be
telling this truth i will be explaining
the situation because
ukraine needs the support of the world
uh
because this world doesn't stop in
ukraine it uh it can expand to other
countries
and we need the support of the whole
world to stop this war
wow
i'm i'm very moved by your story
andrey and i think the community is as
well yeah i just wanted to say before
you leave
there are people who want to thank you
one user says wow thanks for sharing
your experience with us and all the best
to you and your friends and family
another person says please stay safe and
good luck to your colleagues
yeah and thank you so much from us
yeah uh pray pray for the peace and uh
please support ukraine
dimitro while you're here i would
actually also like to ask you um how you
are doing with all of this because uh
it's not only yeah where you
come from i think but also your
day-to-day
work you must be surrounded by this
uh yes yes i'm um
i'm following the news from ukraine
daily and not only on my work shifts
uh so today i'm actually i have a day
off my news shift
sorry we prevent your day off to meet
you
no no no
it was a great pleasure and a great
honor to help you
but i'm also following the news from
ukraine especially nowadays because
ukraine started
uh
the really
successful counter-offensive in the east
in hearty region
and i'm also praying for our soldiers
for their lives because they're doing
the really
extremely dangerous
job
of uh freeing uh of liberating ukrainian
uh villages and cities in the east of
the country
okay
well i wish you all the best uh for yeah
everyone everyone you know there and
yeah i hope that
dealing with this in your in your job is
not an extra level of difficulty in a
way um
but i really wanted to thank you both uh
dimitro and andres for joining us today
um it was incredibly valuable to hear
your perspectives as we said before
we're so lucky to have got to to speak
to you both because
it's very difficult to
very very difficult to
get any reliable information and so yeah
a huge huge respect from all of us here
for uh sharing your story and for
speaking out
thank you very much for having us on
this show
thank you andrei
thank you very much thank you andrew and
take care
thank you
bye
take care too
bye
you